if you haven't seen Verdan you haven't
seen anything so wrote a French soldier
from the front in 1916. it was in fact
just outside Verdan that one of the
bloodiest battles in human history and
one of the decisive acts of world war
one was fought a Carnage said by many to
be unnecessary the French believed that
a network of fortifications around
Verdan was invincible and unconquerable
and had deployed much of their artillery
elsewhere while the Germans intended to
take advantage of this mistake and
forced the enemy to concentrate the bulk
of their troops here and leave them dry
under the blows of their own artillery
more than a thousand guns of various
calibers including the Fearsome big
Berta supplied by 2 million shells
Verdan was of vital importance to the
French and they would defend it at Great
cost it's believed that every French's
Soldier employed in World War one fought
for at least one day at Verdan but
tactics intensive bombing and the use of
gas weapons did the rest even today we
still don't know for sure how many
soldiers took part in the fighting that
so the French and German armies face
each other for 300 days from February 21
to December 19 1916. not to mention the
casualties between injured dead and
missing the number could easily reach a
million as would later happen in
Stalingrad Verdan became a symbol of
resistance and heroism but also of
suffering death and Madness one had to
have passed the through work done to
truly understand the horrors of War
argue their known French soldier and
Verdan still has much to teach us today
if we want to get a taste of what the
world might be like at the end of a
world conflict always just around the
corner a trip there can give us some
answers even 106 years later at the end
of the war despite the Victory and
Triumph a real scar remained of that
slice of Northeastern friends the
bombing had destroyed Villages and
devastated the landscape many unexploded
bombs still undermine the land and
somewhere underground there must still
have been bunkers loaded with weapons
gases and chemical all compounds and
among those fields and forests still
they buried the remains of Untold
numbers of Fallen men and animals in
quantities and conditions that made the
older recovery and burial impossible the
French government in the aftermath of
the end of the war merely isolated some
1200 square kilometers of death and
destruction and proceeded with the first
superficial Reclamation Works hoping
that nature would take its course the
few residents who remained after the war
were moved out and all agricultural use
was prohibited on that land Villages
still intact were abandoned and those
destroyed by bombing such as Ramon never
rebuilt it was cleared that the total
Reclamation work would take years if not
centuries it was called zon Rouge Red
Zone a non-contiguous Wasteland extended
between Lil and non sea passing of
course through Verdan the zohrush is in
other words a land poisoned by the
chemical waste of an exploded Ordnance
by lead Mercury and arsenic by the toxic
reflexes released by animal carcasses
and buried human remains the zonkus
basically corresponds to what was the
front line that is the area where the
fighting and with it the destruction was
total all life is all but denied in this
Zone vegetation doesn't grow and if a
human being even managed to escape the
detonation of some unexploded ordinance
he or she would be immediately infected
by a lethal mix of chemical and toxic
agents think that the Arsenic levels
recorded within this area are around 179
milligrams per kilogram when in Italy
for example the maximum allowable limit
is just to 20 milligrams however the
French government has carried out
remediation works over the years at
least in the least compromised areas so
much so that as of today the zohus is
restricted to only 100 square kilometers
some areas are no longer off limits but
according to experts at this rate it
will still take 700 years to fully
secure the area on the other hand
however the gradual Reclamation of land
considered now cleared and handed back
too quickly to the population has ended
up exposing farmers and the entire
communities to the slow action of the
remaining chemicals this is because the
cleanup work was often conducted rushed
and superficial nature hasn't helped as
recent surveys have found even higher
amounts of arsenic in the soil than
those recorded in the past despite this
farming and hunting have returned to the
recovered territories the French
government and European Union monitor
products from the region but it's clear
that stricter controls would cause
damage to the local economy already
suffering from A Century of living with
the poisons of War of course men's
Reckless actions have also added to the
situation in fact one of the most
dangerous and poisoned areas of the zon
Rouge is located north of Verdan and is
known today as the plaza gas the gas
place this is where in the 1920s
departumondo de Minaj officers detonated
any unexploded ordinance they could
locate in doing so however they made the
situation worse because these
detonations in turn released their own
toxic charges into the ground just
imagine the effects that a mass
detonation of thousands of Ordnance and
Munitions may have had on a once verdant
wooded landscape today the plaza gas
looks like a piece of tundra in the
middle of the forests of Northeastern
France the soil is now superluted with
ammonium perchlorate and arsenic whose
concentration is 1000 to 10 000 times
higher than natural levels that only a
few lichens and mushrooms managed to
grow in this area what's more only since
2004 has a scientific study highlighted
the danger of the area first it was
found that the surface layers of this
soil for at least 20 centimeters consist
only of the burning debris the analysis
then found large traces of copper lead
Arsenic and zinc the Placer gas was only
fenced off in 2005 and in 2012 N3 was
formally banned but the zonhush is only
the in innermost and most dangerous part
of the areas involved in World War One
fighting even larger is in fact the
so-called yellow zone an area that is
certainly less dangerous but still has a
number of unexploded Ordnance an
estimated 900 tons of ammunition and
bombs are recovered each year by French
and Belgian authorities and not only by
them because it also happens in fact
that these devices are found by Farmers
that work in the fields in those parts
they called it recalled the fell the
iron harvest the problem is that under
pressure from local communities a clear
distinction between yellow and red zones
wasn't often made and as a result as we
said some contaminated land was restored
to its agricultural use too soon in
short some stretches of yellow zone may
have Red Zone levels of pollution and
Hazard and when abnormal concentrations
of toxic substances turn up authorities
always remain vague about the possible
causes and this often happens even
beyond the boundaries of red or yellow
zones in 500 municipalities in the north
and Patrick departments that is those
regions located further north of Verdan
along the Belgian border drinking water
was banned because of high
concentrations of ammonium perchlorate
no one has ever provided an explanation
but the location of the contaminated
aquifers corresponds to the places where
the most intense fighting took place
during the war which leaves little doubt
that these municipalities far from
Verdan also suffer from the same problem
even though they don't fall into any red
or sometimes even yellow zones after all
it wasn't only worked on that fighting
took place in Mass further east of
Verdan the local diminished team in
charge of clearing the territories of
three departments belonging to the old
front line registers 900 to 1000
requests for Action a year with a total
of 45 to 60 tons of ammunition collected
as long as they are conventional
Ordnance all it would take is a little
Caution and a safe place to detonate
them but about two percent of those
collect it turned out to be gas weapons
loaded with mustard gas and false Gene
until 1997 such armaments were collected
and stored that specialized the site at
sweep in the mark Department not far
from Verdan given what had happened to
the plaza gas it was preferred not to
detonate them at least for the time
being but when France signed the
convention prohibiting The Possession
and use of chemical weapons those
weapons had to be dismantled somehow so
the Sequoia project was initiated the
dismantling site was established at the
mail comp military base where the
ordinance would be detonated in special
Chambers starting in 2016 marking the
beginning of the toxic waste treatment
program for an expected duration of 30
years what happened in and around Verdan
and the heavy Legacy that has fallen on
Generations a century after the battle
is just one emblematic and tragic case
in numbers of a certainly more
widespread problem that is often ignored
after the war in fact almost all
belligerent countries hid and stored and
used armament including chemical weapons
the problem is that many of these
locations are unknown whether they are
Top Secret locations or long forgotten
Secrets staying in France for example it
was discovered that thousands of tones
of armaments and Munitions were stored
in a submerged chamber under the waters
of lake wri or in the caves of jardel
used as a veritable Dumping Ground and
the more years passed the more Fragile
the casings that retain the toxic
charges became today in the parts of
erdan everything tells of the war from
memorials and Charnel houses such as the
one in Du among to the private
collections of farmers who have
recovered ammunition and Relics from
their fields over the years many
activities revolve around the Macabre
remembrance of the War tours are
organized that come dangerously close to
the Red Zone maybe even Crossing it
trenches are reconstructed for the
Delight of tourists unfortunately it's
when we think we have left the
nightmares behind that which should pay
more attention and in Verdan the horror
of the war is still embedded in the
ground the Zonkers in some parts full
starts under the appearance of a lush
Forest I'll buy the poisoned one in
other parts such as the plaza gas it
seems instead to have some straight out
of the pages of Thomas Elliot's
Wasteland the poem of the post-warf full
of men and his land a Barren Wasteland
where life no longer grows camped with
dead trees where not even the many
buried corpses have been able to sprout
well also today we have finished our
story thank you all for your attention
and see you in the next video ciao